for the past 26 years PlayStation
consoles have been home to some of
gaming's most memorable hits with PS 5
releasing this holiday season it feels
like the right time to see some old
favorites and lesser known games from
Playstations past make a comeback Demon
Souls is already confirmed but there are
plenty of other remakes ports and
sequels that we'd love to see so here's
a wish list for PS 5 some of these games
feel like no brainers perhaps none more
so than blood-borne it originally
released on ps4 in 2015 and rumors about
a remaster have been spinning for quite
a while now we'd love to see this from
software classic get the next-gen
treatment alongside the Demon Souls
remake better frame rate anybody if
we're hoping to see some deadly dragons
on PS 5 we might as well include a more
lighthearted one toys for Bob remade the
original Spyro trilogy for ps4 and it
turned out to be a great revisit to the
series now that the studio is working on
crash for a fresh Spyro game could be
the way to go after that God of War was
one of 20 18 s best ps4 games and while
a sequel hasn't been officially
announced the original left plenty of
room for a follow-up
the reboot was also a technical marvel
bringing together stellar combat and a
massive world to explore presenting it
all in a single unbroken camera shot
with the PS 5 s increased power a
next-gen port would be a great excuse
for a revisit we're also excited to see
where the story goes in a proper sequel
wow that was something that thou jak and
daxter did get a collection on ps4 but
the last main entry was 2009's lost
frontier so it's been a while and former
developer Naughty Dog did hand off the
series to other studios but with the
reveal of Ratchet and Clank rift apart
maybe it's time for Sony to give its
other platforming pair another shot Sony
could also bring back one of its most
popular shooters Killzone 2 turned the
series into a top PlayStation franchise
on ps2 and the most recent entry
Shadowfall was a ps4 launch title
guerrilla games is focused on Horizon
forbidden West right now but another
studio could certainly bring back
Killzone for the next generation and
just like gorilla being known for
Killzone Sucker Punch made its bones
with the
sly cooper series with sucker punch
moving on to infamous and ghost of
Tsushima the fourth game thieves in time
was handed off to Sanzaru games a studio
which was later bought out by Facebook
since then Sly Cooper and Friends have
been relegated to Easter eggs and other
games but with the recent revival of
platformers a revisit on the PS 5 seems
like just the right time for the
globe-trotting thief to make his next
big score let's talk about infamous some
more the open-world superhero gameplay
really showed what Sucker Punch could do
and the standalone last light showed off
some pretty brilliant light based powers
the PS 5s ray tracing capabilities could
make those powers look even shinier in a
port or full-on sequel another classic
from Playstations past that's long due
for a revisit is the twisted metal
series just imagine all those exploding
cars and flying mechanical bits with the
PS 5s particle effects we haven't seen a
new game in the series since 2012 so
this is now the longest gap between
entries it wouldn't hurt to give
sweet-tooth another shot speaking of
action racing games let's bring back
MotorStorm - just like twisted metal we
haven't seen a new one since 2012 the PS
5 reveal event showed a new Gran Turismo
game for the simulation racing
enthusiasts and a new motor storm would
be perfect for the arcade racing crowd
like motor storm Heavenly Sword only
existed on ps3 original developer ninja
theory plan to follow up but it never
came together now the studio is owned by
Microsoft so maybe it's a good time for
another team to bring back one of the
ps3s earliest action games
Parappa the rapper is the only rhythm
game on our list and the last time we
saw a new one was 2001 the second game
did come to ps4 a few years ago but it's
time for a whole new adventure with a
fresh soundtrack the PS 5s 3d audio
could be used for some cool effects on
the songs too fans have been clamoring
for a new entry in Konami Silent Hill
series 2 we were close to getting one
helmed by hideo kojima but it was
unfortunately cancelled perhaps a new
game could be built from the ground up
for the next generation the PS 5 spatial
audio was specifically called out as
being good for horror games with the
player being able to hear monsters
sneaking up behind them so the creepy
nature of Silent Hill would
it right into the tech kijima isn't
making silent hill's or even metal gear
anymore but the Metal Gear series did
compete with Syphon Filter for a while
the stealth action series could be
played on the ps1 ps2 and PSP but
developer Sony Bend has moved on to
other games like days gone still
imagining how realistic lighting could
be used to effectively slip in and out
of the shadows is super exciting
while Capcom never did release Mega Man
Legends 3 a passion for the spin-off
series has remained strong Capcom
released Megaman 11 in 2018 which was a
fantastic revival of the classic series
but why stop there
since the Mega Man Legends series began
on the ps1 a new one on PS 5 would be a
homecoming even ports of the original
games would give newcomers a chance to
see what made this spin-off so special
Capcom has also been ignoring the Dino
Crisis series for some time we've seen
Resident Evil given new life with 7 and
the recent remakes and Dino Crisis could
certainly benefit from a similar revival
the elevator pitch is basically what if
we replace the zombies with Raptors it's
so simple but it's a real shame we
haven't seen another Dino Crisis since
2003
hopefully capcom will consider giving
the series another shot in the new
generation parasite eve has been put on
ice for many years as well the last
entry
the third birthday is 10 years old at
this point Square Enix is already
working on at least one PS 5 exclusive
with project Athiya so why not add
another by giving aya Brea a new game
speaking of Square Enix let's talk about
Final Fantasy Tactics it did get some
follow-ups on Nintendo handhelds but the
ps1 original is remembered very fondly
for its turn-based gameplay and strong
story the visuals only got better with
its rear Elise's in sequels so a
next-gen version would be a sight to see
on PS 5 something like octopack
travelers art style could really spice
up a remaster Squares Chrono Cross was
the polarizing sequel to the classic
Chrono Trigger and it found a loyal
following in the years since its release
the devs really wanted to make a sequel
but it never happened
at the very least a Chrono Cross remake
or even a fancy port would certainly
grab the attention of RPG fans the
original is one of GameSpot's rare 10
out of 10 reviews after all it might not
hold the same popularity as Final
Fantasy and the chrono series but brave
fencer musashi is a beloved square game
to the sequel Musashi samurai legend
even got a dash of Kingdom Hearts flavor
thanks to Tetsuya Nomura maybe his team
could take a break from the insanity of
that series and create a third Musashi
game that doesn't have to juggle all
those Disney movies is everybody in
position
we prepared that's not the only RPG that
could use a complete trilogy either dark
cloud 1 & 2 released many years ago on
the ps2 and both are available digitally
on the PlayStation Store the series
blended dungeon crawling with town
management and it would be really cool
to see that combo at work in the next
generation if we're talking RPGs we've
got a mansion persona Atlas is already
working on a Shin Megami Tensei game for
switch but when that's done we wouldn't
be surprised to see the studio revisit
the smash hit persona series between
five royal and scramble there's a lot of
hype for the franchise right now vagrant
story isn't as well-known as some of the
other RPGs on this list but it was
incredibly ahead of its time
despite launching at the end of the PS
one's life cycle a lot of its praise
came from how it pushed the limits of
the original PlayStation along with its
great story and clever combat so what
better way to show off what the PS 5 can
do than with a sequel or remaster that
once again Wow's us with its art style
and performance Xenogears may be largely
forgotten at this point but its place in
the ps1 library is pretty important it
was an epic JRPG with an amazing story
that explored themes of psychology and
religion and also you could pilot giant
robots a port of the original would be a
great excuse to revisit the series that
eventually evolved into Xenoblade
Chronicles this list wouldn't be
complete without wild arms a ps1 RPG
that stands out thanks to a Wild West
world you can explore using your weapons
and tools outside of combat the last
game in the series is on PSP and it's
been all Quiet on the Western Front ever
since but there was a manga and anime
series which means there's plenty of
materia
that could translate into a new game ps5
might just be the place to bring it back
we're done talking RPGs but we're not
done with Square Enix the legacy of kain
was once an I doze property but now it's
under squares care the last game in the
series was 2003's defiance from Crystal
Dynamics so we're long overdue for
another one at the very least a Soul
Reaver remaster on PS 5 would make a lot
of fans flip out Crystal Dynamics worked
on both Legacy of Kain and gex and we'd
be happy to see that gecko return on PS
5 between nack and the return of Crash
Bandicoot it just might be the right
time to bring back another platforming
mascot this one just happens to be a
talking gecko who makes some cheesy
jokes so this has never Neverland you'd
never guess it from the inside
and if we're digging back further into
platforming history a new jumping flash
might just be a welcome surprise it
actually holds the Guinness world record
for being the first 3d platformer so why
not embrace the technology of the PS 5
and why us again that 3d audio and
haptic feedback would probably work
really well with a robot rabbit bounding
through the sky there's been talk of a
bully sequel for years now and since we
finally got one for Red Dead Redemption
it's time to cross your fingers and hope
that bully is next Rockstar Games
certainly isn't shy about wanting
success on PS 5 GTA 5 is already
confirmed for yet another port on the
new console the getaway definitely took
cues from the GTA series and from all
sorts of British gangster films so
there's certainly plenty of material to
inspire a new one thanks to guy
ritchie's the gentlemen and Gareth Evans
gangs of London which itself is inspired
by a video game of the same name
alright let's bring it home how about a
new Space Jam we are getting a new movie
with LeBron James taking over for
Michael Jordan and the dual sense
controller could probably simulate the
feeling of dribbling pretty well if you
ask me it's a slam dunk
MJ deforms it dog okay so that is
obviously a pretty exhaustive list but
I'm sure you've already thought of a few
games we've missed that you want to see
on the PS 5 let us know in the comments
and stay tuned for all of GameSpot's
extensive next-gen coverage
[Music]